on your life everyone's going out
welcome to Street Coco yeah it's our
last day here at Comic Con and we're so
excited to have to finish off the week
very special guys john roberts and
eugene mirman Bob burgers yes oh
goodness oh goodness and we're gonna
play a little Mario Kart today very
exciting
Jamison you actually got a free one of
these at the TV Guide yacht last year
that gave us a free we and I played a
lot they they have a yacht it's an event
they've bred ok yeah I was gonna say I'm
just gonna say all right I'm gonna be to
start off with me baby Mario oh and just
sweeten the pot today the winner winner
of every race will get a sweet lotto
ticket partly because I bought too many
of these in the beginning of the week
we're just gonna get rid of some so it's
gonna be fun that's just to have some
kind of stakes as if it matters all
right I don't know what to do here so I
just pick whatever oh that's right kkf
via John Roberts Eugene for the win
there we go
and a little purple party no they love
you guys oh oh that's great I don't know
I'm just yeah alright alright and let's
do you want to go we'll just go a
hundred and sees that that's fine you
don't care how fast we go 100 CC's
untwine seems good a little little Mario
Kart Stadium start with start with the
basics
yeah just great so how's Comic Con going
fellas
great it's been fun whoa so much fun
yeah too much fun actually have you guys
did you guys do a panel already you did
fantastic honor to go who's fun great
awesome
come on solid questions please get any
more advanced they're going into like
deep blue characters yeah like you like
it
have you seen guy have you see people
dressed up as your characters yeah and
also a lot of it is like whole family or
like groups of people dress patois yes
that's awesome
all right what am i how do you all right
uh a a is gas right trigger is is like
items and left trigger is kind of like
drifty okay that's ID
the Leyland here use this to use that
yeah there you go I'm in last if that
helps anyone I'm in a little mo oh
what's that
who are you are you Donkey Kong I am
donkey oh yeah Oh perfect oh he's
already in third I'm doing the worst
well how am i am i doing great you're
six your six
yeah it's great your kid walks better
than eleven Oh God
oh yeah well yeah six is better than al
oh that's right how many comic-con's is
this well I've been coming for 900 years
yeah the first one I came in here was
with Andrew Jackson why am i falling
yeah Andrew Jackson was a Trekkie I just
think we owe a lot to the Trekkies
comic-con would probably not even exist
yeah yeah they started it all they're
the original they're kind like the
pilgrims of time they were the first
people to really enjoy outer space
yeah that's true that stories about
goodwill in outer space
oh you turned it up you don't want to
hit a banana peel oh my goodness you
know how I found out
Wow what happened was I hit up your you
hit up and what are you uh I got I got
all Sparkle or you I got you are now no
no no no what are you guys looking
forward to or what have you seen just
personally there was an awesome silic
like silicone mask of uh just what do
you call it I'm superheroes and things
that I put on that was nice wow that's
kind of cool
yes yeah there's a nice mask place I
guess a mask technology not to get a
look at our a man it really is it's
racing students there was another
costume design place that did authentic
kiss outfits like the band Kiss yeah oh
yeah they had like the
and all kinds of cool chains yeah you
put it on and right away you're like why
do I eat women a lot of the special
misogyny picnic yeah just inject
yourself with somebody told me that kiss
actually sells kiss themed coffins
sounds like it's like right it's not
really that surprising uh hey you know
maybe just one and embrace it death God
I really enjoyed that I'd be flying that
does everyone keep flying or no yeah
just everyone flies there yeah it's just
a just a lot of flying that's great
Phoebe I came in last
all right here's it here's a scratch
wait do you whines who's got the bomb so
you want the cool cat or do you want
ESA's and eight pieces any basis in AIDS
you go for it go for you get it for us
what do I do here well I think we're not
sure I think you just scratch it off and
see what happens
yeah yeah mail it in just write the
scratch to see what happens I don't know
up to $20,000 exactly next race next
race here we go wait from scratch off so
that's excited about the masks I'm
excited about the masks
I saw a lot of comic books that seemed
really fun what do you read these days
what well I love fables I love Astro
sitting straight and then a lot of a lot
of uh like the new 52 some of that that
stuff is great yeah absolutely so I've
been reading a lot of that so I kind of
just love going there walking around and
it's also fun seeing like even beat up
copies of like the first appearance of
spider-man yeah it's like that's where
stuff is pretty neat
it's very yeah it's it's it's really did
you collect comics as a kid I did
mylar the backing the whole stuff yeah
yeah boxes yeah - yeah - OH
that's exactly what you did you get
anything I don't know is it
incomprehensible thank you for 20,000
good yeah you know cute now all right
well whatever fun there we go great
there we go awesome who's your key back
okay all right ex race all right let's
do this let's cool so and you guys six
seasons coming out in September
yeah hey hey are you all ready you must
re veeery yeah yeah we record sort of
nine months out I think that's on before
it airs September 27th is the premiere
yes very cool is there anything you guys
are specifically looking forward to in
the new season or no just everywhere
gripped reading has been cacophony it's
just so funny yeah yeah the scripts are
getting better in there there's more
you know like secondary characters that
you like Paul Rudd's gonna come and play
Tina's imaginary horse Jericho which is
yeah so funny
and even like the clip yesterday of
Tina's the guy making a Latina oh yeah I
feel they're like ramming his tongue
down her throat
it was so no please swear away swear why
is this wearing braces yeah okay give me
a little Linda's wearing baby oh why am
i under water my in danger no I think
you could breathe underwater yeah great
I know the yeah it's funny that I beat
my laser and the dragon breathes under
buzzing back honey
could the oh look at that why am i
holding
oh come on
I did get some go I got a good heavy
metal poster ooh there we go I had some
good heavy metal poster I have you met
oh you mean the comic heavy yeah like an
original yeah like a sign Godzilla
like a plastic big plastic Godzilla oh
my god that's awesome yeah 43 year old
needs and you know what they don't grow
up it's a trap that's what I say yeah
it's kind of like I'm really I'm being
like a huge nerd I'm super excited like
they like all the crazy merchandise and
everything but it also kind of bums me
out I wish they had that kind of stuff
when I was a kid you know cuz now it's
like huge but like that I feel like as
we were growing up they were just
starting to get the hang of like like
steena were like everybody had Star Wars
figures and that stuff right now it's
like you get like the big like
statuesque figures through so it's hard
not to buy that so I'm gonna have a huge
amount of toys I don't have ready in
comparison to the yeah exactly
Lego I had Gobots I never ever really go
by no cobots were good Gobots were a
good time Rocko's was my jam Oh Legos
yeah the Star Wars Legos are pretty
exciting oh hell yeah now like Lego has
all these those video games and stuff -
yeah yeah and they've really figured it
out I saw this great somebody in the
office got an awesome
Tamiya Star Wars a cool little statue of
Darth Vader as like a samurai overall
ever I made her oh it's awesome
the first year come about I got a really
great Sulu alone oh
Sulu Cologne what are you gonna was it
called
it was called I don't know like Sulu I
can't remember I mean it was those I
think the first time here I was like
there are ridiculous things and then of
course when I brought it home
it was like why do we have why do you
smell like Sulu oh yeah smell like a
master story that's that's that should
be the slogan smell like a master
swordsman in outer space
exactly he was persecuted a ripped he
was ripped yeah
hey guess who we been Booker Presley
from Revenge of the Nerds wow that's
awesome the show we used to reach
starstruck actually was that's awesome
right of the Nerds one of my favorite
movies of all time yeah and I actually
get a little teary eyed when they do the
speech at the end force how can you not
I always get teary-eyed also the Goonies
speech yeah like this is our time yeah
down here yeah yeah yeah it's all part
of it so I feel like it's like part of
our DNA right and I and I haven't seen
Kramer vs Kramer but I bet though guess
it divorces are touching yeah yeah
i-i've never seen Kara's Grover what if
it was just the Benny Hill theme for 90%
of that's true interesting interesting
choice
you probably yeah will forego the lotto
tickets we'll just all distribute them
at the end that's like that she confuses
to configure yeah no it's just like
ridiculous all right anything look good
here what do you guys well were they all
I mean that's really fun let's play the
leaf thing sherbert land sure this cuz I
really want some sherbert yeah no great
rates right so for people people who
don't know you guys in Bob's Burgers the
scripts are written but you guys also
kinda get to improv we record all
together a lot of cartoons you go in and
you record alone yeah and what we record
together as a group so that's a play off
each other and then improvise and stuff
that's really fun yeah see Boyle
we're spoiled you get to Brienne you
breaking the song a little bit I do over
egos
little sing-songy yeah I heard somebody
ran into you guys at Hotel I heard you
had an amazing c-3po belt that's true
yeah is that a comic-con is that a
recent comic-con person did you bring
that too cuz I was saying Fred Segal in
LA purchase comic-con is definitely the
best place to order that the best yeah
we're done or else that's a cartoon
isn't about a dog you know that sex out
of wedlock or so yeah but then it's like
actually that's not and it's forgiven
it's a very it's a it's a touching moral
drama with cartoon dogs
I adopted a a love child basically what
happened is this woman didn't get her
dog fix and then she had a play date
with another dog and then she got you
know the dog operator so whoa one of the
literature yeah I just hosted a big
puppy based event in Chicago of hundreds
of dog uh it was like this Animal Planet
thing where they wanted to have the most
shelter dogs like in one place and
adopted oh it's like an adopt-a-thon ER
so I was in adopt-a-thon yeah with rock
and roll and comedy oh my god that's
kind of exciting
yeah and did any was a successful their
lives in dusk oh yeah I think yeah they
brought out a lot of cute guns and they
all got adopted Oh
what's your I I always love when pets
are named like long ridiculous human
beings you know
yeah like a Ditto fun you know
or human the better me exactly what mold
them into our species eventually it's
true yeah at first they started out just
by being friendly and then we feed them
an event also be able to play games with
us right what's Gino I think that's his
name it's like this freaky little robot
that's big brother like areas just
connected to your soul it's like it's a
spy I know it's the futures I don't know
what you're describing it sounds like
it's somewhere between the NSA and
something I could buy it's a whole
personal robot basically and it's
connected to your election all your
whole all your bills and it's so real
what's reminding you it talks like to
welcome all you you you know oh really
yeah it's like a Skynet with a hobo then
how do you get or not get it starting to
sell them now like whoa yeah are you
guys like really are you technology guys
and I love the edges gadgets I don't
have an Apple ID yet but I have a pebble
ooh there we go so that's like that you
want an apple I do want one laughs
anyone who's watching this owns a
company or has technology to mail me
please do yeah or just has gadgets at
home they want to send you that probably
less likely yeah old flip phones yeah
exactly
blackberries exactly no need for any of
that but adapters you know I depended a
bit I just come in yes you did
what oh my son oh wow I really wow I
really so you right you got started on
the gadget talking just yeah and then I
was just like I'm squirting my way to
the front look at me
where did your will that's great what
are people saying I have a toasted I
believe that is the exact reason I do
not want
oh yeah oh yeah no I know why Dick Tracy
called he wants his i watch back yeah
Thank You squad sure okay there you go
should we just read people's names would
they enjoy that yeah let's do er er no I
don't know well I didn't know that
whoa what's on uh I usually a single
animus I don't know how to what an item
is or how to use it
yeah there we go I think this is how I'm
going to find out I am at someone you're
like pinball wizard but yes this seems a
little mocking doesn't it have you
killed my good try extra hose for
dunking I don't know I guess it's like
you can read me it's too fast
hey me I Heidi but uh what what show is
do guys do you guys have time to watch
other shows other TV shows oh yeah
recording once a week Bob's Burgers
takes up all my recently watched a bunch
of black mirror I mean I watch a lot of
it is like the seasons have ended but
Game of Thrones yeah yeah oh yeah for
sure so am i picking a new yeah yeah
it's picking you guys I had so much fun
as that but oh well I could be a little
devilish
I'd rather be oh you know that's a cute
little angel I'm gonna be yeah a
princess in a cat suit this feels very
comic-con to me yeah I should probably
maybe I'll go get a cat suit yeah sorry
oh this is anniversary
oh yeah no yes if the universe undergoes
the elastic part I have every all the
knots learning episode
maybe that's what I watch yeah are you
serious what no Falcon Crest just not
imsd
Knott's landing yeah I never got into
the Aquacraft interesting like best
friend Clarence is dad watch your father
Congrats oh whoa there we go wide meet
my mom wheezed watch Knots Landing
together what no what do you love now
now for people who might be too young to
know a Knots Landing is yeah these kids
were google it yeah what do you love
about not slamming the little and big
urban drama yes sir so is it not what is
nothing what it should I don't know if
I've ever watched not slam dates its
soap opera from the 80s yeah okay oh
it's a place that flaming is a place
yeah
California like a Arab League every it's
about garlic knots landing and right
yeah that wouldn't that I would I'm just
really hungry yeah yeah yeah this is one
the rest of everybody on Conan's eating
and you have to work that's right that's
well work well if you're not allowed to
leave yes good point yeah the microchip
in my neck will shock me oh that's true
great yeah so you guys you're diner what
else you doing what else you doing now
you guys are you've done your panel now
you just get to roam free yeah well yeah
I mean just high five
I stay for an extra day so I'm gonna get
to walk around it's cool oh I see I am
in a different place and you get you get
you guys get recognized I mean your
voices so if you close your mouth and
you keep your mouth shut
oh yeah when I walk around like when I
walk around John Benjamin we're just
both like hey what do you want to get
yeah
what do you think those people are like
I don't know who that is but it's
definitely not dream yes somewhat people
you know most people are pretty Pleasant
sometimes people like yesterday when we
went to the TV Guide boat to do
interviews yeah there was someone who
there's like lots lots of people who
want you to sign like photographs that
sell on eBay
we're not necessarily yeah there yeah
there and then one of them had a picture
of Kristen and was screaming like it
wasn't I guess it wasn't threatening per
se but he was going by the picture of
you you have decided I was like oh my
god that's a combination of terrifying
enough so if you so don't do that people
that's weird and terrifying little
signing etiquette for you guys I don't
scream like I'm gonna like go to like
I'm gonna fight you I'm gonna play it
was sort of but uh but really actually
it's been very nice and you know what
like the panel was so fun and everyone I
don't know meaning like people who are
kind of touched by the cards family it's
just very nice yeah it's you just you're
the upper 12 and 12 is one of the worst
places that's right oh no your info
thank you Andy I'm in a pan thank you
for joining us see how to chat in DNA
can't say hi he's concentrating boots oh
hey you won't believe how popular you
are indie on this stream we're talking
about gadgets yeah are you a gadget guy
Andy um I used to be more so until I
found children that ate my money oh yeah
do they like gadgets yeah yeah I know
we're uh we're definitely a screen
family every mound as bad as some people
but but it's still bad enough people
that are like you know oh you can't have
you let your kids watch you know like
it's basically they're bitching about
letting kids be on screens it's like I
challenge them to get my daughter to
stay at the table there we go I'm saving
up for a star studio
every it starts to do oh look that's a
nice that's a nice grouping yeah yeah I
don't know which one of us was where
John were you know I was 10 oh well he
plays it cheap John please come on
really
yeah last time I came in second and I
used to I thought that's what I you're
still paid better than the rest I love
it it's already breaking yeah this is
this is Bree oh there's braces oh you
know it's funny I only learned about
gaps and left and right
sorry that's that's that's pretty and
then what if some of the others do and
then that'sthat's items this society you
know you came in first without any thank
you yeah what I've been coming in closer
to 11:00 yeah so items Oh Andy how's
your comic-con back um well I've been in
the vicinity of it I've never been doing
you haven't walked around no can you
walk around er do you get too many high
fives I don't know
I didn't experiment you have to try it
though you don't enjoy it you'll be
trapped in this hot to walk around that
rubber band ass which is what everyone
says you have to do we're not a rubber
mess but a really good nice soft plastic
we go a little then a little bit just
like a stocking cap like a bank robber
yeah that way you'll it'll be like some
recognizable aunty hose right disturbing
it like you guys let me get the best of
both worlds yeah uh squash our house
Andy what's your favorite 90s baby 90's
band
yeah well the 90s were terrible yeah
they were a terrible terrible time to
music you got you got your Gin Blossoms
in there
mashmallow oh no no heaven smells about
morphine morphine was a very good night
he's been working yeah they're our 808
state they were good ooh hell yeah
Ricky think turkey ready like some
tricky elastica master breeders dorita's
for good sonic you hide the galaxies at
night man
my mayonnaise baby where they have you
bridge the gap I think they're yeah
you're getting yeah you're doing quick
what are water I'm gonna try to you I'm
not you know when you say items I just
pop it's like it's like 10th 11th 12th
you guys are all next to each other
fantastic guys like friends lovely
well Landis Morissette hype somebody's
dead oh yeah jagged little pill hand
just swallow it down love it oh I just
hit a streetcar yeah poison Slayer is
asking I see you guys are you friends
with Kyle Gass I'm wondering that I am
if that's Kyle watching the chat are we
friends remember me hi Kyle yes yes I
did did you get to record with every
guest oh I guess I did another drink
I did oh that's really it was the best
animated recording session I've ever had
just bond and collaborative and really
exactly how it should be that's and the
best-looking best looking well a lot of
it was a phone patch so Jon Benjamin
wasn't there and he is the real
sweetheart yeah he's the next place yeah
we keep John in a secure area by himself
is that hitting a bad women me John you
went too fast now your games over look
at me and you team works go I didn't
realize let's go playing fighting
stopped I stopped playing I thought we
were done
I don't think I'm gonna catch up from a
lab well place our 11:11 here 11th oh I
see sir I just had it bad games good God
andis voices maybe things you guys have
and being voiceover guys you guys have
to protect your voice to you you warm up
do you have tricks you do that oh my
gosh Rory yourself would your trip late
some tricks on this - no I know I long
it's actually can a problematic yes they
can get probably tomatoes and chorizo
hard when you're recording injuries at a
children's show and you can't speak and
they ask you why and you say bomb just
horrible just good I just go turkey
gravy just drink coat that throat yeah
delicious Turkey good all right speaking
of which I'm gonna go because I'm gonna
save my boys it's crazy I will say like
it has been I feel for you guys we don't
normally do an hour of streaming every
day and my voice is gone today yeah
yesterday I started losing my voice do
you guys ever Eddie do you ever show up
to a reporting session you're like I
don't have like I'm at it
no no no no there's a few your
professions that's your job well not
even that like if you were like if you
had a cold and you lost your voice you
wouldn't report we were currently a year
out oh right away
another time if you had - got it you can
be sick for work got each other to get
now they know you're fighting gene
and then they are there I do you think
they're ever gonna put out like bloopers
or anything like that there are there's
actually a semi thing with on the first
year's more seasons DVD Lauren put out a
few haunted Soundcloud Beej - I think
he's got oh really
oh wow you're so a blooper about a thing
that was cut but God animated because
they almost kept it oh but it was who
you can see online where every guy think
we're talking about it why we love
grandpa and like that he gives us gifts
and then it's like he goes five dollars
and then there's like a version where I
said yeah he lets me eat as much Tylenol
as I walk ha ha it made everybody laugh
a lot and they loved it then at the last
minute they're like you can't have a
child stay but it's like but it's online
it you can watch like that little clip
oh there we go nice job dad yeah
what was the what was the audition
process like there wasn't we got all got
gas is that true yeah whoa that's
awesome yeah meaning Lauren we sort of
like the in the characters are sort of
you know like Linda is like basically a
character that John Roberts has been
doing on YouTube who's basically his mom
right god yeah yeah well yeah I was a
starting point there and then yeah I
mean all of us everyone like he kind of
agreed some around us that's cool so we
would you know when we improvise you
have stuff to draw he you know he's he's
really good at bringing that out and the
writers are really good for writing for
us yeah I guess like come it's own thing
you know for sure
so like Tina was originally a guy named
Dan yeah and then turns up Dan makes for
an excellent opportunity oh yeah for
sure that's exciting
which Saudis the all right from your mom
and then actually it is yeah really oh
yeah yeah my mom one time we went to the
Las Vegas in the 80s and we got bumped
up the first class cuz our landlord work
through the airliners doing well and
when the plane landed my mom would I'm
Ryan
nice land so we just would make one of
that for that that was the 1987 all
right like what I think so when I first
started doing I was like this is gonna
be my dynamite you know
it actually happened I was like oh my
god that is fantastic
oh I love it yeah your mama's vetoed it
she's so into it
he's so she owes you man she is oh I owe
her it's I will say like it and in terms
of like no one makes you laugh harder
than your family everyone has such a
weird like dysfunctional like crazy
family that it's like that's got to be a
real thrill to be able to like share
that with the world
yeah yeah yeah it turns out there's a
lot there's a lot of Linda's out there
yep you know I mean my mom's from
Brooklyn yeah you know Joe during that
time it was a big you know that sure
yeah so guys I love it we're just
bringing up the rear yeah doing this is
fantastic
the worst part is as I'm trying dude
it's we're all Trump we're all trying
know when you're in when you're in
whatever but what 12th place gap you
know I have a year I'm you're a bro I
think if you run if you're dueling soon
have you you know but thank you you
you're still doing right and remember
you won without using a single item
that's huge I did do that once yeah
the other times I that's who I shouldn't
do that that's the one thing you can say
today yeah when we will ask me what you
do today I'll be like you came in second
and Mario also think this guy knows what
he's talking exactly also you know if
you guys can't get enough with Eugene on
Bob's Burgers you also a star talk
yes star talks amazing Jason O'Malley
creeper the core love starts off great
thank you Jason and yeah we're all
obsessed with space what yeah what are
some amazing things not to switch topics
to space very quickly
yes what's like the craziest thing you
think you've learned the people who
search for extraterrestrial life in
reality like not fake but remaining look
for it yeah believe that we all get
signal from a similar like an advanced
enough stabilization though that I was
like 25 30 years whoa within our
lifetime
meaning the the speed with which you can
point right basically like a radar or
whatever antenna or like satellite dish
and send a signal and then receive a
signal like into Goldilocks planets yeah
they think that you know statistically
it'll be in about whatever my god that
is a amazing fact but are they gonna be
hostile
no no just there isn't there right
that's what I would want Hawking said
that oh yeah yeah but there's a
difference between like we can send
basically like we can send rock and roll
into space that's very different from
going to another planet right so what
we're talking about is finding a
civilization that basically it you know
has the technology of like us like
though you know 1970s beyond or
something yeah you know shoot Taylor
Swift hours yeah exactly
get her newest ticket yeah yeah about
their values come here the reason that
I'm thinking they're probably not here
is because if they do come here they're
as I think Neil and lots of people of
play up Stephen Hawking is when it when
an advanced civilization comes to a less
advanced civilization the less advanced
always again so suffer yes exactly
they only suffer yeah yeah he was my
favorite oh he was so those terrifies I
let me spit out here
but I'll still try to feel feel people's
faces sometimes hi it'll be like nope I
love thee
so if you see Eugenia comic-con you
starts to try to paw at your face yeah
and you're a lizard person rock you
still uncover you it's true yeah if
you're an actual lizard person yeah look
out yep exactly
oh so no comedy bang bang coming up if
you guys watch that oh yeah yes the
thing on there that's awesome
that's we're not what are you gonna be
what are you gonna be doing I play this
guy Jeffrey sleazy and he's gonna he
wants to market Kid Cudi's got this hand
puppet no you wanted to kind of market
it that's awesome
sleazy sleazy sleazy that's fun what was
it like shooting it was best I love
Scott Aukerman and me that show it's
just so funny yeah the format's very
pee-wee's Playhouse and it's other you
know it's just yeah everything's so
funny on that show to me event that you
could play a really big character to you
oh yeah and it really does feel like the
spiritual successor to pee-wee's
Playhouse which is awesome yeah it's
really sweet absolutely amazing
I just saw the Wayne white documentary
which is have you seen that which is so
what is it a cure it's like so pretty it
hurts my feelings or something and it's
amazing cuz he you know he did a lot of
the art direction for pee-wee's
Playhouse and Oh was the guy who does
have you guys been to fred 62 la there's
a store in Melrose
did he design that yeah yeah yeah yeah
and he also does like the the big right
like that windings and he'll write stuff
in them that's what beauty is
embarrassing that's what it is it is
iconic that said you know when I saw
Beauty live on Broadway a couple years
ago it was like even more done up
version but it was never like wow this
set is genius absolutely it's classic
and it's like I feel like it
it's that shows influence everything
including Bob's Burgers like yeah it's
like that kind of humor is
the culture you know it kind of it made
it like okay to be completely silly to
be an adult yeah that's one way you
gotta do guys somebody I was watching
the chat you got have you guys ever seen
Rick and Morty do you like that show
yeah oh yeah cuz that kind of it has the
same kind of feeling as like this insane
like same guys well done here well we
plugged in 2014 yeah there we go
I never get into all the customizations
I'm not into all that stuff okay I think
my last game you guys alright last game
for all that he could count all the
cookies or whatever last should we
played you want to play which is one
right let's do one race one last race
for you I'm going I'm going the big guy
here this big scary dude going
intimidation if you guys feel
intimidated I'll be baby Daisy schemas
for all the cheese oh my god something
isn't it buffets are me favorite lunch
meet everybody sound off but it was
strongly pastrami vegetarian do you know
mugged you go a bit mushroom mushroom on
there well I'm not a crazy mushroom
person but I'll make up homie biggie
burger alright and I'll do like
something like a fake meat okay
alright you know phony baloney phony
baloney there we go every once in a
while I mean baloney is not basically
not a meat anyway yes yeah you're
circulated as me s my mom needs to make
good meatballs I remember oh there we go
yeah
what's happening my mom's balls your
bike yeah but all right I'm sorry this
is Robert oh wait what's happening here
wait I think I messed up I didn't let
her know I got excited when I said I did
yeah I did I completely uh here we go
Jess what is our last game yeah yeah
laughter last race Ericom said we're
gonna go we're gonna let's go through
let's race uh this is their last race so
if you guys have any questions ask him
now this is for you aware that Saul
right this is pretty Qi America this is
let's do it
yeah if you have any questions shoot hit
him up yes got a favorite shisha what's
today what's it out of that class
there's a really great one for you know
why I like a drunken goat cheese that's
my delicious drunken goat cheese what is
that that's the system
yes oh yeah along with the I'm not
planning anything I just got this image
of you like in a hotel room just covered
in cheese watching not slaughter yeah
yeah no we're like good wearing house
being but you're c300 it seems Threepio
felt was killing it
they made me speak I like a hard cheese
I'll go a parmesan I'm gonna parmesan
I'll go a Joey
another it's like a hard cheese you ever
put a little ricotta cheese on a nice
little piece of bread with some honey on
it oh my goodness
right yeah delicious oh my god are you
guys foodies I like I do like Zeek
blades look yeah this guy knows all that
we go to the best restaurants on tormek
ug grill all the spies yeah we were
pretty spoiled on tour it's a better
awesome yeah lady Jean you traveled
obviously all over do yeah and if I've
been to Rhode Island thank you not to
brag my goodness gracious they won't be
able to be like ooh he's so good do you
have a favorite place to eat in Rhode
Island no okay but what's the cuisine
with the road I Leah Rhodes Ian Rhodes
Enoch whiskey like I don't know lotta
Lotta couscous so I probably see foodie
here see that's kind of obsessed
let's wrap though I travel to the Rhode
Island Beach a to Touro Boston is really
really good I love that place there we
go
what's your favorite like kind of
cuisine you guys say somewhere between
Asian and like tapas okay mine's
vegetarian organic it's my scene with
you oh I like it little I like fresh
organic veggies some tempeh okay you're
gonna outlive us all Oh
kena oh good I hope I'm hoping to dive
into this summer yeah yeah just end it
quickly right
I know after this comic-con I feel like
I'm already I feel like I'm dead and now
I've been reanimated
I look like like water right now
you got the hungover hat on the hangover
hat ever getting foamed Kirkland
government's yeah yeah I've been a big
tequila guy this time oh yeah I feel
like I was a big whiskey drink where I
lived in New York because you know gets
cold and you want to kind of Carol yeah
exactly an outfit in LA now it's like ah
whiskey's make me so sweaty I just gets
us and so I gotta go tequila you know a
god tequila's always so apparently the
only non depressant alcohol oh it's
another or that it is an upper oh look
at that
there we go that's why when I drink a
lot of tequila I don't shut up yeah
maybe I should replace my coffee in the
morning which is tequila eight a.m. to
bury of me exactly to killing the
champion that's our that's our pretty
work ritual I'm just saying it's not
until you're drunk during the day that
you realize how much fun you can you
know wrong you're just like you're
walking on a cloud then you wake up
already years later in a puddle of your
own piss yeah it's not so pasty although
those 20 years headed up to there are
amazing thank you guys yeah there we go
yeah I just don't think about it sorry
well bye bye awesome Thank You joggers
7:30 on Fox Sunday nights and the knees
in I'm premiers on the 27th of September
very exciting and also start rocking
this car cause if you watch the thing
I'm gonna put up it'll make you smarter
it'll make you smarter fantastic hop on
in
awesome see you guys later thank you the
oh here take these lotto tickets for you
there take all these lotto tickets if
they win more than $1,000 I want two
bucks back
there we go
wait that's right just this does the
items ok this drifts this is gas yeah
this is dry yes I mean if you want to go
forward okay what if I don't
I like uh-huh like in life thank you
exactly oh that was really exciting I
love Bob's Burgers my favorite shows
that was great and I gotta say it is
super weird
it will never get not weird to see
people who do famous voices in person
doing those voices it's just it's just
so bizarre can you hear the voice that
it's coming out of a face you don't
recognize or you just don't you're not
familiar with which is great I remember
it's so funny when I first started at
Conan as an assistant I would talk to
one of my bosses wives all the time and
I talked to her on the phone for almost
a year before I met her in person but we
were phone friends you know like do you
have a phone yeah and then I met her and
it was so weird because it was like I
knew her I knew who it was
oh you know well yeah but it was coming
out it was the same thing we kind of
talked about this yesterday with Laura
Bailey and Travis William put like one
Mike judge was on Letterman and seeing
him do beavis and butthead was just so
it looked like it was dumb it was so
weird like what the hell very very weird
all right yeah jump in jump in O'Malley
creepers coming under the camera the
camera ended this week the way we
started it so like that's right give you
some tingles case of tingles be very
nice in the chat because no one has man
that's right don't make it don't make us
dive it have to ban you exactly I said
press a everybody I say oh my goodness
that's right that favorite cheese yeah
she said Gouda Oh Mouse favorite cheese
ah I'll be jack Colby jack Wow
hybrid cheated oh snap
I'd be worried no I know you yeah you
can Mario people worry about it or I'll
be waluigi okay Wow why do we why Louie
I'm gonna be under God some weird thing
here what's this baby buggy
oh wait where's the other sneaker I'm
going sneaker sneaker um guys favorite
moment from our shows this week it's a
favorite moment so far maybe I haven't
happened yet maybe it hasn't happened
I'm half again it's a great I don't know
there's so many good so many good yeah I
love the origin story or disorders
let's do this ready I think we got to
wore a gold mine we got the rainbow road
or what should we do check tell us tell
us what cup we should do chat ready we
got mushroom flower star special egg I
kind of just like the egg cup yeah Oh
mystery cast yes tonight yeah we have a
very special show to finish out our week
we're very very excited
top secret show spoiler alert Conan will
be appearing on the show tonight Conan
O'Brien and Andy Richter will be on the
show tonight I mean keep that under your
hat
our band our band multi to them I'm
seeing eggs special egg Bell egg all
right a lot of people are using cheese
cup should be a cheese joke yeah it's
been a crazy week I love it
yesterday here's a story from yesterday
I think I just gave a trans story right
about the taking the photo right so
yesterday so that's idea to do I don't
know if you saw we tweeted out a photo
of Conan with the Game of Thrones cast
doing an awkward prom photo but but so
the idea was to get that photo myself
and Meghan said Clara the photographer
for the show
we were gonna get it it's great it's
very hard to get a photo of 13 people
all at once so the only place they're
really gonna be together it's like on
stage so the idea was after their second
after their second interview segment
we're gonna run up on stage and I would
kind of scream at them hey can you all
get in the line it will take this photo
that's kind of what we did for the
Hunger Games photo with Jennifer
Lawrence yeah I and Liam and Hutchinson
and so so we're waiting we're waiting we
watched the interviews we're at the back
of the theater and all of a sudden the
show ends because we ended with their
interview when we did something called
crashing out and when Conan crashes out
it means he goes straight from a segment
into saying goodnight and at the end of
the show you know we shoot we have
something over the credits or whatever
and so we couldn't run up Megan and I
couldn't run up on stage to get the
photo because it was they were they
didn't cut to black they were shooting
the whole stage and so I started getting
I a felt like I was gonna throw up oh my
god I started swearing a lot I was go my
god what should we do what do we do
and Megan was like I know maybe we
should ask Hollander to bring them all
back on stage just like oh we can't keno
because we're in front of the whole
audience everything let's all say all
right let's just run backstage this far
on crack stage you see if we can catch
them there was like a watch things
people were like eyes on Glee yeah I was
yeah yeah we were like so we ran
backstage and Conan's rip backstage and
he's like bleh what's up I was like hey
man I was like I didn't I forgot we're
crashing out tonight we didn't get the
photo what do you think about going down
to the Greek should we go down the green
he's like yeah let's go let's go let's
go so he grabs his jacket if you like
run down to the green
and luckily down there in the green room
which was full of people because they
with 13 awesome cast members and then
all their people know turning the
controller doesn't and that's it and so
we were down there and so luckily they
were because they don't get to see a lot
of each other
they were just taking a photo of all of
them together and so kilt Conan came
down and I was like oh hey great let's
get a photo of Conan and so we all did
and then and then I was like hey and
this is very nerve-racking for me
because it's full of their people and
the entire game of Thrones cast and I
love that show and it's weird to like
talk to I mean I still get starstruck
after all these years it's like hey this
is kind of a weird idea but would you
guys be cool at taking an awkward prom
photo and they were like yeah let's do
it
and and so I was like okay everybody
kind of get in the line and I was just
like pushing couches out of the way into
like other people and I like this one
woman she was like ah so y'all really
started that and then now so all right
everybody line up and grab each other's
hips like a conga line and it turns out
Conan's will be later I kept saying you
know I was in like a haze and so I was
like weird take a profile from oh and
then and then company later said and he
actually asked everyone there it's like
do they have prom in the UK and
everyone's like no so no one knew what I
was talking about they just thought this
person came down it was just like
yelling prom they no idea what that was
but they were all extremely nice and we
got the photo and it was very very cool
and it all worked out but yeah it was a
it was a crazy time that's right yeah
Beth reason asking if they're backstage
photos
role in the interweb only thing that's
right that's right and you got a cone in
Twitter to add Twitter common or Brian
and he linked to it yesterday so that
was really really fun and then yeah then
we got a great Hunger Games trip pic
which is fantastic those are like the
nicest people I am I they were super
cool and here we go said woo more cheesy
stories
[Music]
it's a cheesy story
[Applause]
you're unsaved a lot there the one of
the Instagram with you getting the
Jennifer oh yeah that was great yeah we
just ran up and and it was so funny and
he's a coda thought it'd be funny to get
a photo of Jennifer Lawrence
photobombing him and Liam and Josh and
they're just so nice and they were like
game for it I mean all the guests this
week have been absolutely fantastic and
just an absolute pleasure and all the
fans - I mean you guys have just been
really really cool and whatever we were
onto you guys in the street I mean
people made it into the shows have just
been unbelievably awesome and remember
if you guys want to get a pop doll your
last chance is watching tonight's show
so Conan's gonna announce the code for
tonight and and you have a chance to you
don't have to be at the show all you got
to do is watch the show
[Applause]
where did some sort of thing go yes I
had crazy crazy a lot of stuff happening
I'm winning we've had at the window open
I think we said this because of the air
conditioning yes all right hot this
building was coping like the 20s they're
not selling the pop dolls at we are by a
window yes we have to be by the window
because there's no air conditioning here
this gets very very hot all these all
these sexy folks in here and once again
yeah we are our last show from comic-con
is tonight 11 p.m. TBS mystery guests
it's gonna be awesome we're very very
excited it's been a fantastic week and
and also if you want to see all the
stuff we've been doing yes use the
hashtag Conan con if you want to yeah I
love it I love it tense so he said
what's the matter cut against break the
window unit you can't see this but the
window is like it's honestly like eight
feet wide
there's no yeah and we can use them
anything you enhance the mini switch the
other camera window so it's like you
just crazy there's no way no way it was
gonna happen
no it was gonna happen
no way a weeble girl thank you yes the
comic-con shows have been an absolute
delight we've had it's just such a blast
but we knew we knew we were gonna have a
blast because our fans are so amazing
video like this is the last day of a
streaming video games from comic-con
there will be a clueless gamer in the
next few weeks or in the next month
we're actually doing shows next week and
then we have we're off for two weeks
that's right that's right I have to slip
it on my husband's back that's right
because you've just been thinking about
the x-files reboot yeah that's all you
can think that's right that's right
the exciting oh man I'm just in the wall
over here yeah what yeah what
dude this is a hard level that's great
parody yeah yes this is great for us a
nerdy folks to thank you guys for
joining us for the stream oh man yeah
thank you you're spending your Saturday
doing this there's like people yes we
appreciate it
I was so cool and thank you again to
John Roberts and Eugene Mirman for
stopping by today at Bob's Burgers you
could follow Eugene and Andy as well you
could follow Eugene on Twitter at Eugene
Mirman and John Roberts at John Roberts
fun on Twitter of course Bob's Burgers
airs Sunday nights at 7:30 on Fox yeah
we've had some great great guests this
week oh man look at that bullet I love
the boy this is better than going to the
pub that's true and guess what this one
for us to this room smells way better
than a public only marginally though
just lets it still smells sweaty but
just less beer smell less George
marinelle's like to thank cheese lately
I've been getting into the extra-sharp I
really got into like some super sharp
cheese lately wait you guys know about
Jason O'Malley he's a Chipotle fan oh
yeah maybe they might not know about the
quesadilla burrito thing oh the
quesarito acacia arena explain what that
is they take a quesadilla and then could
make a seat at first and then they grab
burrito ingredients in the quesadilla
yes I would not do it if there's a long
line cuz they'll you'll draw the ire of
the 15 what time I ordered 60 McNuggets
and I wasn't drunk I was by myself in
our 60 maybe nuggets and ate them all
and when they brought them out to me at
McDonald's the kitchen clapped they
talked about everyone in the kitchen
claps and by the way when you order 60
McNuggets they give you as many sauces
as you want
throw that out there that was incredible
that's incredible okay yeah fifty
burritos great Bambino
that is a lot British although I have
eaten ten burritos before wait I don't
look when my heavier my heavier Dave's
favorite x-files character like tubes
tubes
Tam's Lula fun that was me I like a nice
edgy cheese that's what I'm saying my
Daniel I like a parmesan
he's like created from the sewers oh
yeah
I'll give me garbage that's me you ain't
playing that's me garbage that's me
that's the final race final race mofos
all right this is for all the cheese's
exactly hi creeper huh did you enjoy
Ella's burritos I did enjoy Ella's
breo's the race in 32:22 I ate ten
burritos and ten tacos by the way I used
to do that regularly which is why way
heavier than I do now
you're the cheat day - yeah the garbage
brunch that's awesome
I ate all this stuff that I never I
can't I really want to get sponsored by
some kind of food products that we could
just eat it freely on the stream because
I'm allowed to eat allowed to eat
unhealthy food if it's for work that's
why yeah somebody was like why don't you
fill the bag of mystery with like hummus
and carrots I'm like short oh I'm
starving
it's like chris farley that's right
twitch.tv / Team Coco past broadcasts as
well this one this will be in a past
broadcast
they're all yes I'm YouTube and you for
joining us for the very first time
welcome and we normally stream every
Monday to do a thing called Monday melee
and that is a twitch TV slash Team Coco
and youtube.com slash burning and yeah
we will not unfortunately be streaming
this Monday because well look at my
shirt look at my shirt everything done
and also we have to play this is boring
but we have to put all this stuff back
on a truck and the tribe yeah the truck
is not getting there too late but
hopefully I be streaming from my house
over the next two weeks the creeper
would come over and look at it set that
up my shirts be x14 my shirts are from
all over the place I get old them a lot
of them from screened comm sk ree any
d.com and actually i've made a couple of
my own which is kind of fun so maybe one
day we'll link to a t-shirt store of
ones I make but I did not make this one
I bought it on screen comm also a hot
topic in the girls section I get a lot
of stuff in there
dude I'm 11 we're bringing up the
atmosphere of course
Finland kill the Hitler okay and yeah
make sure to make sure to watch the show
tonight yeah you want to watch it
tonight I need to don't watch it tonight
you'll hear about it tomorrow that's
right one day you guys see me crazy
costumes favorite costume yes I saw an
awesome someone came people been showing
up to the shows and cosplay and Conan's
been going out in the audience and
taking pictures with people during the
commercial breaks we attack yeah and he
took a picture with a girl he's dressed
as vet you know the Jeep how you say
vegetto from Dragon Ball Z with the blue
and the she had like long black hair
which is great and then like the big
shoulder pads was fantastic it was
amazing
all right guys well this'll do it for
our week of stream cut go
Conan Kahn look at this right here thank
you all for joining us we've had a great
time this week streaming with you guys
and again will not be streaming Monday
but we will be streaming in the very
very near future and thank you to all
our fantastic guests who came by this
week especially from Bob's Burgers John
Roberts and Eugene Mirman again Bob's
Burgers our 7:30 Sunday nights on Fox
thank you to Petrosky Jane a creeper
Jason O'Malley in the corner thank you
you guys beat such a great time and
please watch the show it's going to be
amazing tonight we're very very exciting
they were very very excited and check
out hashtag
Conan Con and us on Instagram and all
this other great stuff all right that's
it we'll see you guys watch the show
tonight Limpy MTBs thank you for joining
us see
[Music]